but you sometimes I think it's good to  take account you couldn't you can like  drive people to things you don't realize  what you're doing I think you can make  people crazy I think you can and like  when you look back woman I think I I  definitely crazy but that is way too  much holding a night if that's extreme  I think you have to be in them but you  as a person could definitely ignite the  worst side of a human being good like  that yeah I agree I think your ears are  either crazy or you're not and either  have it in you or you don't like there's  a baseline I've been in toxic I've been  in a toxic situation where I very well  could have acted crazy but that's not my  character I wouldn't do that so you're  either the type of person to do that  [ __ ] or you're not I don't basically but  the way yeah girls ever brought out the  worst in you because I know I've done it